here's a deacon what guests had to say
after the show the Keystone pipeline is
a terrible idea
great common sense again the oil
company's a lie it's like saying if
Canada said to us hey look we want to
run a pipe of the sewage through your
company did you find do it we would all
say no right this is the same thing and
that we're going into these oil sands so
desperately looking for this oil it just
seems like a giant waste your dad was
the oil right yeah yeah my dad well he
owned a gas station answer me don't know
my dad was in the oil business yeah but
I you know they're never up front with
us ever about anything and I don't know
why we just don't learn that lesson
about these oil but it's as simple as
that to me okay
Michael why is Bradley Manning not seen
as a hero like Daniel Ellsberg was with
Watergate well I think a lot of people
do think well I think he is a hero yeah
what am i if I were president I'd have
Cheney and Bush and Wolfowitz all
arrested and they'd be tried for lying
to the American people I can't think of
a worse flaw I could tell they think I
country to war is it really a worse lie
that a politician could tell them to
take people to war and have thousands
hundreds of thousands killed it's it's
an effect that Bradley Manning is gonna
serve life in prison or be executed
because all he wanted to do was tell us
how we were being lied to this is
disgraceful and historians 100 years ago
if we're still here are not gonna look
kindly upon this do you is there
anything you think is off-limits to put
up on the internet for everyone to read
you know anything in the government that
that shouldn't be put out for anything
in the government don't nothing nothing
no what about you don't know out CIA
agents do you well this is this a good
it's actually a good question because
I've been told since then Ghazi last
fall that that was a consulate or an
embassy and now we learn it's a CIA
station yeah
the black ops thing of well I mean Chris
Stevens wasn't part no not him but I'm
but the actual the reason was certainly
it was why people in the neighborhood
might have been upset if Saudi Arabia
invaded us tomorrow right and suddenly
somehow was able to take over and they
had a consulate stationed down on you
know Pico and Fairfax who here might not
considered paying them a visit
I'm not saying it's right I'm just
saying I I know your whole thing with
people and Muslims and Islam and all
this but my whole thing just my whole my
whole thing is about people's believe
not that they're Muslims rights that if
they believe something inimical like if
you hear someone as I've heard
congressman say that they believe we
don't have to worry about global warming
because in the Bible God promised Noah
he wouldn't try to wipe out the earth as
a congressman said you would say that
belief is harmful when I hear someone
say their belief is that if you leave
the religion we could kill you yeah
that's not prejudiced on my opponent I'm
not a bad guy I'm not going greenwald
I'm right I seriously I I understand
that's why you usually win the argument
because you're right we can do the Book
of Mormon and Trey and Matt are not
going to be killed right I I get that we
can't do the book right but my point my
point with Muslims is that they don't
want to take over America they don't
want to invade us they just want us to
[ __ ] out of there I agree and leave them
alone and let them work it out and
eventually the oppressed in most
countries will be free yeah yes that's
where I was going with that question oh
about energy independence we are soon
going to be energy independent in this
country self-sufficient so well yeah we
don't need to get it from the Middle
East any more and when we do I don't see
any reason why we need troops all over
the world
sorry-sorry will be energy
self-sufficient we won't be independent
of the the repercussions of Middle
Eastern oil be interrupted all of our
economic partners we have other
interests in the Middle East we've got
interest from our relationship with
Israel to the fact of nuclear
proliferation to the fact of terrorists
we've got real interests in the Middle
East I don't think it should dominate
u.s. foreign policy but there are
reasons not to simply walk away from it
okay Andrew were circuit our banks still
too big to fail he wrote the book which
was the great movie on HBO's two big
davila now we are in a more precarious
situation than we were in 2008 okay good
and bad news the banks are still too big
to fail that's the bad news right good
news is I don't think they're gonna fail
anytime soon oh great they will again at
some point unfortunately no
unfortunately the opposed to feel good
about now unfortunately the economy is
still so lousy we talk about
unemployment all these other issues
there's not enough debt and leverage in
the system that's what that's what took
us sort of over the cliff laughs last
time it will happen again it might
happen in five or ten years or longer
but for right now you can you can count
what's the date you can kind of chill
out no III worry about the size one but
I I don't just worry about the size of
our banks today I worry about this the
municipalities the cont the the
countries the states you know too big to
fail we talked about it when I wrote the
book about about banking now it's about
everything and I think that's that's
what we need to worry about more right
now okay well right now we're not gonna
worry we're gonna party thank you very
much ladies and gentlemen Real Time with
Bill Maher and Friday night at 10:00
ask bill and his guests to her questions
right after the
at hbo.com